Isis the latest Isis update yeah all the
beheadings the burnings all that stuff
continues but I actually found signing
that was actually kind of positive
related to Isis if that's actually
possible this grandmother this elderly
woman on the streets of Syria who
started verbally assaulting Isis members
and it's really this woman is absolutely
fantastic
these guys are beheading people they're
shooting people astray they're burning
people alive and she is probably 80
years old and fearless this is this is
beautiful
two things I thought when I saw this
video one now I know why I can't reach
my mother she's in Syria at least she's
yelling at someone else yeah and she
might have been a hundred and well it's
very stressful there so maybe that's
aged her a little bit more but really
this is this is an amazing thing right
no I mean once I I know how that how
that soldier probably filled one time I
had Jimmy Durante yelled at me it was
really yeah and and I gave him a kiss to
build a dream on how do we empower these
people because every video that we see
about Isis is this horrible stuff and
we're gonna do a segment in a second on
whether we should even be showing those
videos or whatever but this thing to me
was inspiring i watch this and I was
like oh there are pee
people there that have the balls now
she's at the later years so maybe she's
a little willing to take some more risks
than you know a 16 year old she's gonna
throw her life away exactly
but really like she's got some like this
is the time this is the thing that
should have went seriously viral yeah I
guess I'm dubious of the authenticity of
this video as I am about many of these
videos because I don't understand who
shot it right I'm confused by where the
camera is and right he did wires that it
was an Isis guy in the car so either
maybe those guys weren't Isis I don't
know you know we don't know we don't
know this is the problem there's really
essentially no way to authenticate
mm-hmm also like I mean it's good it's
great yes she's taking a stand she
doesn't they they see there's talk in
there about the Kurdish guy who they had
killed and and she's saying why you know
why did you kill him
don't kill anybody you know it's good I
mean if you read any of the stories I
think a piece in was it I think in the
Atlantic I might be wrong and then
another piece over the weekend that they
believe in the end times so they don't
care like that it was a nice explanation
and there's a couple books coming out by
some serious people not crazy Fox people
about who these guys are and why they
and if they believe that well then at
least it makes some sense as to why how
how these incredibly barbaric acts could
actually be being yeah what's these are
actually Sunnis right so thus in Syria
we have the same problem because as
Sunnis are being like I don't know in a
sense disenfranchised from their own
land right so we went in [ __ ] up Iraq
we screwed over the Sunnis so now they
don't have so all those people who we
kicked out of Saddam's army are now it's
called used to be called al-qaeda in
Iraq the other called Isis right so
these are all fascists former trained by
Saddam which means they're trained by
the Russians which means that so that's
who these people are and they're Sunnis
and this problem isn't going the way you
can't bomb our way out of this problem
and so that woman's right in that sense
but I don't think if that woman would
have walked up to George Washington in
1790 whatever 74 and said stop [ __ ]
killing the British then we would've
stopped killing the British when you're
in a war and you usually believe in it
yeah and by the way to talk about how
crazy the alliances in are and all that
I saw this week that we're now gonna let
some of the rebels in Syria call air
strikes with our air force to bomb Assad
so we're basically the rebels air force
now so it's all just it's Joel just this
be
freaking mess so last thought on this do
you want to get to that point in life
where you just don't give a [ __ ] that's
what I kept thinking about that woman
she's at that place where if my mother
my mother to bring her back do it you
got there I think at age 35
she's been doing it for about 55 years
but really don't you want to get to that
place where it you just don't care so
that these people could literally be
doing the worst things imaginable and
she has she has more balls than anyone
we know from 1999 until the middle of
2000 I was that woman I did not care I
was super depressed as in a major
depression and I used to get on planes
going I dare you to fault either dirty
to crash go ahead I'll give a [ __ ] you
do me a favor so yeah I know exactly
what happened then I took started taking
Zoloft that'd be like a third
[Music]